Let's go to the phones at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty, starting with
our caller from the old stomping grounds of
the David Pakman show in the four one three
area code.
Who's calling today from four one three?
Hello.
Yes, that's you.
And if I'm eligible.
Yes, you are.
Hey, David.
My name is Sean.
I'm calling from Watertown, Massachusetts.
I have a question about one of these men.
I'm not so happy about it, but I read that
the odds are better that guys die.
And they're basically saying that every one,
every time a good opening on the part of my
practice, I'm saying that it is the companies
open on you for all their taxes and all that.
And obviously it was self deport themselves
or transferred to a college, which is often
important.
That is is quitting.
Yes.
Let me see if I can.
Let let me let me see if I can explain it
to the audience.
And in the meantime, if we're on speaker phone
or you're using a Bluetooth or something,
please turn it off.
We can barely understand you.
But let me explain to the audience what you're
saying.
It goes on to say that we there has been an
audio speaker, phone calls every day.
It just just barely.
So what what's going on is many schools are
going to be online only in the fall.
And what the Trump administration is, I don't
think I can hear you.
OK, Oberg, I'm going to let you go and then
we'll.
I'm not exactly sure what's going on there,
but maybe we can build a better connection
with the Trump administration is saying they
are going to do is if you are a foreign student
here on a visa and your school is going online
only they are essentially saying you've got
to go.
You're going to have to do your online classes
from your home country.
It's becoming a very, very big political disagreement
and for four important reasons.
And we'll have probably a more detailed report
on it at some point in the future.